[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATT GAUNT: So the one thing
that I remember you mentioned
at one point was
command-line shortcuts,
like keyboard shortcuts.
That's still another thing
that I've got no knowledge of.
The one thing that I hate
is when I type in a command,
and I realize it's
not what I want to do,
or I need to tweak
something that's
in the middle of a command
that I've already typed.
And then I have to just
delete the entire thing.
It just takes time.
What command-line keyboard
shortcuts do you use?
ADDY OSMANI: Something
that you're probably
doing every day is using your
arrow keys to navigate around
a line.
MATT GAUNT: Yup.
ADDY OSMANI: Right?
So one thing you can do is
you can Hold-Option and then
click on a position
in the current line
to go straight to it.
You don't need to
use the arrow keys.
MATT GAUNT: So
Option is Alt on Mac.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
MATT GAUNT: Yes.
ADDY OSMANI: And just click
on the position in the line
and navigates straight there.
And it works, right?
It's kind of useful.
I also like using
pbcopy and pbpaste.
They're these commands that'll
let you pipe in information
from a file, straight through
to the clipboard in case
you need to use it.
What other shortcuts
do I like using?
Well, sticking with the idea
of navigating around a line.
Control-A will move you
to the start of the line.
MATT GAUNT: Nice.
ADDY OSMANI: Control-E will
move you to the end of the line.
MATT GAUNT: How do you
just delete everything?
ADDY OSMANI: Control-U
will clear out
the whole line for you.
Kind of nice.
MATT GAUNT: Nice.
ADDY OSMANI: And
you've got control
over a whole other
set of things.
So Control-K can delete from the
current position of your cursor
to the end the line as well.
And Control-W will
delete from the cursor
to beginning of
the current word.
MATT GAUNT: Nice.
ADDY OSMANI: There's a ton of
different shortcuts out there.
MATT GAUNT: So basically just
control hit a random letter
and see what happens.
ADDY OSMANI: This is how you
end up deleting your code, Matt.
MATT GAUNT: Shhh, it'll be fine.
ADDY OSMANI: Again.
[MUSIC PLAYING]